today we reached an agreement on you  regulation which will help us to promote  the railways all over Europe passengers  will have more choice and better service  especially better route alternatives we  want to bring railway on board as  competitive mode in order to speed up  the corporatization efforts this new  framework is helping us to open up the  market for more innovation let me just  mention some of them single ticket the  flexible ticket electronic ticketing  wireless services on board trains better  access to trains an enhanced comfort  sense similar also we discuss about  emission testing of cars with  Commissioner beyond Kafka she presented  a result of the latest technical experts  meeting on the testing of emissions in  real driving conditions and she promised  us that she wants that package they  should pass at least at the 28th of  October in their console we must really  push on the zero emission cars in the  future so that's that's the real point